My next guest is also in this book.
This is gonna be the thread
through the whole thing, okay.
I thought you were reading this book.
Please welcome Jay Larson.
Jay how are you?
[Jay] I'm great.
I didn't know if Austin was
done dropping any more credits,
you know what I mean?
He's gonna pop up as a picture in picture,
like when they play, you
know, the less important game,
that's a blowout
and he's gonna be just
dropping credits in there.
'Cause he's booking things as we speak.
He just booked right now.
Are you working?
Are you staying busy?
Oh yeah look at this.
[Jay] I saw you asked Austin
if he's done any commercials,
I directed a commercial
during this whole thing.
Yeah, and then just for future reference,
if you could take all
of your questions based
off of Austin credits,
it's gonna help us do a
great thread for the show.
[Jay] That's you know what I mean?
I like unity and concise.
Yeah, okay.
So you directed a
commercial pandemic wise,
which is it's already difficult
enough to do a commercial
cause it's a hodgepodge crew.
People that have not worked together.
[Jay] Yeah.
Are we, are you doing this remotely
Or are you onset?
No, we did on set, we did two days.
One day on set in a church
and then another day out at a golf course.
Are you getting rapid tested before
or are they just winging it?
Got tested day before
we had someone on set.
You got your temp checked
three times throughout the day.
Everyone's in masks, social distance,
masks off for shooting.
But you're in a mask the whole time?
Yeah.
How does that work, cause you like to,
when you direct you like
to scream an actor's faces.
[Jay] I get in people's
faces big time, bro.
You have a breakfast so
you're, you're on your game.
Don't eat my raisins.
[Jay] Get away from craft, sir.
Kevin Nealan was our lead.
And so like, I have such
respect for Kevin Nealon,
like trying to give
direction, I'd be like,
Hey Kevin, what if we, and he's like,
Oh yeah, you're gonna love this.
You're going to love what I do here.
And then everyone would just be laughing,
you're like, yeah, yeah,
let's let's move on.
Don't got to do anything.
Yeah it was great.
Are you going to do more of
those or was it such a weird
experience or was just like,
let's just wait or you like work?
[Jay] I had no problem with it.
I'm on a, I write on a show
and I wrote and directed five sketches for
the show during the pandemic as well.
I think if everyone is just
cautious and you're smart
and you're safe.
I mean, you're seeing
commercials with people in masks,
so clearly they're making
content or shooting commercials
during Covid, you know what I mean?
Unless Jeep grand Cherokee
knew about this and they
released the virus.
Are they behind it?
Is this something Lee Iacocca, you know,
was ahead of the game on,
I know that might be an old
school reference for you and
maybe some of the audience,
but I'm educated and I'm informed,
you know what I mean?
Yeah, you're informed.
It is, it does change the
relationship onset a little bit.
It's a little less collaborative
and that everyone's afraid
of each other.
And also the writing room can be weird.
I've been in some writing rooms
now where you don't know if
your joke that pitch bombed
or it's zoom bombed and it just crashed.
[Jay] Yeah, or there was just a delay.
What if it, it crushed?
But the delay was so long,
you missed the tire response.
Yeah, and then you already back out,
like if someone pitches a
joke, it's like, oh yeah,
so then he fills up the back
of the truck with a bunch of
toasters and then that falls.
But yeah, I don't think we
have the budget for that.
So we'll just, yeah, we'll move on.
[Jay] Yeah, well we can, we
can rip on the guys maybe,
maybe later.
Yeah, I'm in a writer's room,
I have been the entire
pandemic and it's like crazy.
We have some people in
Florida and some people in LA.
So we were, you know,
like working out times
and just making it work.
You just get so comfortable on zoom,
just being like, well,
let's just make it work.
I think moving forward,
industry-wise writer's room and even
some sets will be a little
bit more remote because we've
proved that it can be done.
[Jay] I hope not. I hope that listen,
I'm all about being safe and
we've been like completely safe
with our kids and like groceries.
I haven't eaten out anywhere,
but I also believe that
like when we get control-
I say DJ Khalid, yeah.
You know what I mean?
Once we get control of this,
that we should,
writer's room you need
to be next to people,
with people, riffing,
like getting a sense for them
seeing them, like that's like,
there's such a,
it's such a part of the creative
process that I think like,
I hope maybe there will
be some rooms that will,
I think we should use it as
like an advantage to be able to
be remote if someone needs to be.
But otherwise I think
being in a room together,
like really benefits the writing.
Yeah, absolutely.
Because it is an energy thing
where you need to throw out a
bunch of bad ideas to get to the good one.
And you can only really feel safe
doing that when everyone's doing that,
and you're all in the same
room and you can pick up on
certain social cues,
like you'll read comments with this,
I could live habits like,
Oh, this podcast boring.
And it's like, well,
it's just different than
being on stage having to
deal with this delay.
I also think when you're in a zoom room,
you're constantly like the
clock is constantly ticking.
Like when is this ending?
Whereas when you're in the writer's room,
so you might just like accept
joke because you're like,
well, this thing has
got to end some point.
Let's just get that joke done.
Whereas in a writer's room
you could like be like,
all right, let's just wait on that.
Let's go work on this. And
like, oh dude! You know?
How are you handling it with kids?
Are you homeschooling?
You're supervising homeschooling.
I'm not a big,
I don't want my six and a half
year old on three hours of
zoom call.
So we de-enrolled them from school
and set up our home as a homeschool,
and then we hired a teacher,
that we like went through
the COVID process with.
So now she like every day
nine to two is with my kids,
and like they do project
based learning activities,
learning.
They do field trips, you know,
it's a lot more organic and
a higher engagement level
than zoom.
So you hired, so your
essentially a principal.
Yeah, I'm VP, my wife got the principal.
I mean, it's not a big deal.
It's not a huge deal.
Seem really upset about it.
[Jay] It hasn't been a thing, dude.
It hasn't come up. It
hasn't been an issue.
I'm not saying I have better
credentials or whatever,
You know what I mean?
Do you have the same power as your,
your wife as the principal.
[Jay] Don't, you know, the
structure of the principal,
vice principal?
I'm the fun guy.
Vice-principal kind of
seems like, lunch is over,
you know, kind of serve at the lunch room
and then you're back in.
[Jay] Yeah, that sounds right.
That's kind of, that's pretty accurate.
You move everyone's cars when
the car needs to back out.
[Jay] You gotta move cars, you know.
Hopefully you'll get a promotion,
So it's also on you to
kind of keep the kids busy.
I saw you're building stuff,
You built a whole science
experiment table outside.
I just love being
interactive with my kids,
and so we built a science table.
I built them a Lego table.
I like doing adventures with them.
Like when the whole thing started,
my job was like the
first two weeks of COVID,
they were like, let's just be loose.
And the kids were out of school,
so like, I would take them on hikes
and then find a picnic table,
and we'd like collect leaves
and turn them into projects.
I just liked that idea, of
like constantly making learning
a fun experience, you know?
Yeah, it's a great time
to be picking up leaves
and anything you find
on the street right now.
You know, like, what is that bacteria?
What better way to learn about COVID?
Getting COVID.
I think your kids are
gonna find the vaccine,
on one of your leaf trips,
which is actually them
just cleaning the yard.
Listen, when you say leaf trip,
it almost sounds like
you're de-valuing it.
No, it sounds like I
actually want to go on it.
It sounds like you're a
great dad and talking to you,
makes me wish I had a great dad,
because it sounds, it sounds fun.
It is fun. Yeah.
It is very fun. They're fun.
They're wild kids. So they,
they, they take to it.
What else have you been
doing to keep them busy?
You've been showing them movies?
No.
Not at all.
[Jay] You know, what I did
is I've been doing, like,
we did this field trip to the beach.
We went to the beach with
like my buddy and his kids,
but we've been watching Goonies.
Are you a Goonies fan?
I wasn't allowed to watch
a lot of movies growing up.
Like I thought Star Wars
was the most boring movie,
Cause my parents had edited
all the violent parts out.
So it's just a movie,
a bunch of people talking
and then a brown bathrobe
falls on the ground.
Totally sucks.
No, I have, I've seen clips of it,
but I haven't seen the
entirety of the movie.
[Jay] Yeah, well Goonies,
Goonies is, you know,
it's Spielberg dude.
You're like, dude, this
is Steven Spielberg.
And we showed it to the kids
and they fell in love with it.
And you know,
there's a treasure hunt and
there's a map they follow.
So after we watch it, I took
the kids to El Matador beach,
which has got like rocks and caves.
And I made the night before, a
treasure map and made it look
old and like, you know,
put old writing on it
and put like the rocks.
I drew the rocks and put X marks the spots
so we got to the beach,
buried it in the sand by our mat.
And then when my buddy got there,
I went and took like a stick
that was charred and put Xs on
the rocks where I had
written them on the map.
And then at lunch, I was just like,
have my hand in the sand and
I was like, Oh, what's this?
And I hand it to my son
and he was just like,
(gasping) Dad!
And like the kids lost their minds.
And then we went on the treasure hunt.
We found the Xs,
I bottled coins or brought
them and then hid them
and the kids found them.
And then it just turned into like,
their whole world was like,
we got to find more treasure dad,
we've got to find it.
We got to dig.
And I was like, I looked at my buddy.
I'm like, should we tell them
like that this isn't real?
And he's like, no, dude, let them go.
I'm like, all right.
So now they just like,
they believe that One-Eyed
Willy from Goonies lived.
So now they're just going to
believe that every scenario
is, is possible.
You're going to be in
your regular day life.
They get on a bus and they're like,
this is the bus from speed,
don't let this bus stop.
They think this is baby
Yoda for real dude.
Dad has the hookup with a
very homemade version of Yoda.
What if someone else found
the coins on the beach?
What if, what if you accidentally
blew someone else's mind?
[Jay] I had the coins on me,
and then when we get to the X,
when they wouldn't look,
I would just go (whistling)
and I just drop it down and be like,
hey, what's that? And then
they'd be like, you know.
Dads a genius.
[Jay] So Burr, you know,
Burr is a friend and
Burrs in the Mandalorian,
and the kids made a video
and we sent it to burr like,
hey, you were so great in the Mandalorian.
And then he sent them a
message back and they were just
like, now, like, you'll see
my son, like talking to kids,
like on the playground or in
the pool and he'll be like,
Hey, have you seen the, have
you seen the Mandalorian?
And the kid would be like, yeah.
And he's like, do you know,
episode four, the guy,
the bounty hunter.
And I'm like, Hey, just chill out, dude.
You know what I mean? Like-
He's already dropping names.
So your son is and that's
been a challenging experience.
That's really cool that
you have that, that,
that hookup and that you can
do they, so they say like,
dad's cool.
Dad is the guy.
They think I'm pretty cool.
You cook for your kids.
Do you go all out ? Like
it's Mac and cheese and-
Pasta. I do real plates,
real glasses,
forks.
There's no separation
anymore. No plastic plates.
Little Vino, come on, loosen it up.
You won't get drunk. It just pairs well.
It opens their pallette man.
You want them to try new stuff?
Give them a little whiskey.
It's for their palette, it
needs to be more distinguished.
I put rum on my daughters
gums when she was teething,
when she was real young.
Yeah.
I'll never forget it. Like
just holding her here,
dip it in and just be like
rubbing it on her gums.
And she was just like, oh
yeah, this is pretty tight.
I'm like, Oh nice.
And then like, she went to bed and like,
we had been having a problem,
getting her to go to bed and
I just crushed it with this,
Captain Morgan is what I gave her.
And then I hear her crying
like a half hour later.
And she had thrown up
everywhere in the room.
Yikes.
[Jay] Lightweight dude.
Yikes, so this concludes our
child services interview.
We'll be following up with some forms.
[Jay] W-what do you mean?
You're a great dad. We
want you to write a book.
I love it.
But anything else that I skipped over?
Talk sports, anything you want to plug?
What you got coming up?
What's the, what's this podcast
we wanna check this out,
cause you tell really great stories.
It sounds like a dig.
I don't know, I stopped
podcasting during this as well,
But there's a bunch of episodes somewhere.
I had one called The Through
Line, that's out there,
you can check out the commercial.
I just shot for Callaway
with Kevin Nealon,
it's actually a short film.
It's like an eight minute short film,
which you can check
out Callaway's posting,
if that's of interest to people,
if you're into branded content,
That's our whole audience,
and then Through Line
is the, is the podcast,
which is, you tell great stories on that.
Yeah.
Very nice.
Just put some whiskey on your finger,
put it in your mouth,
Listen to this podcast.
Jay, thank you so much for helping us out
and doing the show.
You got it, man.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah, this is fun.
All right, later Moses.
[Moses] Later!